sembra un po ritmo del mio battito
cardiaco adesso il viaggio di oggi
inizia da qui
l'essere umano si forma e già riesce a
percepire luce e suono meglio ancora
riesce a percepire espressioni
emozionali di luce suono questo perché
la natura è meravigliosa utilizza dei
linguaggi che ci permettono di
comunicare ancora prima della parola
ancora prima del gesto
la natura è fatta di luce e suono e li
distribuisce sapientemente in grande
armonia luce e suono sono i linguaggi
che la natura utilizza per raccontare la
sua bellezza per farcela conoscere per
farcela apprezzare così da condividerla
e poter preservarla conoscere e
condividere la bellezza aiuta generarne
di nuove aiuta a mantenere viva quella
che abbiamo tutta intorno a noi e dentro
di noi nella parte più profonda del
nostro essere umano bene più che un
punto di partenza è un punto d'arrivo
nel senso che durante il mio percorso
sono arrivato a questa consapevolezza
attraverso svariate esperienze e ha
avuto la fortuna fin da piccolo di
conoscere quelle che comunemente
chiamiamo le varie forme d'arte
la danza la pittura la musica ricordo
degli episodi in cui la mia insegnante
di pianoforte cercava di insegnarmi in
tutti i modi il sistema dodecafonico e
le scale e io sentivo la musica e non
volevo altro che suonare nella stessa
maniera i miei zii fin dall'inizio hanno
cercato di insegnare l'utilizzo dei
materiali nelle varie tecniche
pittoriche la teoria del colore
io non vedevo l'ora di avere in mano i
pennelli e per imbrattare tutto quello
che trovavo sapete i bambini hanno una
percezione molto più estesa rispetto
agli adulti hanno una visione nitida di
quello che li circonda e lo percepiscono
senza costruzioni
e quindi ogni luce suono sono degli
stimoli fondamentalmente facevo quello
che mi piaceva poi man mano crescendo
acquisito acquisitore le capacità ho
migliorato la tecnica e forse ad un
certo punto ho cercato più quasi di
diventare bravo piuttosto che sentire
cercavo forse una distrazione delle mie
capacità con me stesso e nei confronti
degli altri e piano piano mi sono
trovato da solo nel buio in silenzio
avevo perso la luce sono e non era un
problema di bollette semplicemente ero
più concentrato a cercare di migliorare
una tecnica piuttosto che utilizzare le
mie capacità per raccontare i miei
pensieri
tutto attorno a me era stato oscurato e
il mio confronto con la realtà era un
semplice confronto superficiale
ho viaggiato che viaggiando ho
ricominciato a sentire i suoni dei
luoghi e delle diverse culture e ho
ricominciato a vedere i colori e ho
ricominciato riapprezzare il sorriso
delle persone che incontravo e piano
piano ho ricominciato a sentirmi parte
di questa grande armonia finalmente
avevo ricominciato a percepire la
bellezza ogni luogo ogni situazione
avevano un senso ogni colore suono erano
uno stimolo per emozionarmi
e allora ho ripreso con forza queste
espressioni artistiche che aveva
acquisito e ho dato a loro un ruolo
fondamentale provare a raccontare tutta
questa bellezza nella storia ci sono
stati grandi artisti grandi uomini che
hanno investito tutta la loro vita per
cercare di raccontare la bellezza
chi è chi ci è andato veramente vicino
chi l'ha sfiorata chi si è perso
nell'immensità di un tramonto e chi
nella profondità di un'emozione ma com'è
possibile raccontare qualcosa di così
grande
provate a pensare a un tramonto è una
cosa talmente grande e infinita che è
difficile riuscire da raccontare e come
si può raccontare la felicità in un
sorriso e come si può riuscire a farla
percepire dovevo trovare un modo e ho
guardato indietro ancora una volta e ho
pensato come fanno i bambini quando
vogliono raccontarci qualcosa ci
prendono per mano allora che ho preso in
mano luce suono musica e colore e li ha
uniti in un'esperienza emozionale da
condividere con voi è andata così
non volevo un applauso per questo nel
senso che questo non è un elogio
l'artista per me è un elogio alla luce e
suono perché il credo che vivere
un'esperienza artistica aiuta a
migliorare la percezione della bellezza
vedo e credo fermamente che l'arte sia
uno strumento che aiuti a migliorare la
percezione della bellezza
così se noi avremo più percezione della
bellezza riusciremo a condividerla
riusciremo a generarne di nuove ea
preservare quella che abbiamo e quindi
credo che dobbiamo riappropriarci di
questa capacità è di riappropriarci
della bellezza che abbiamo così come
scriveva dostoevskij la bellezza salverà
il mondo